le président lui est loin du tumulte
français il participe à un Conseil
européen à Bruxelles principal sujet sur
la table la guerre en Ukraine et les
livraisons de munitions l'objectif c'est
de fournir un million d'obus
d'artillerie à l'Ukraine au cours de
l'année à venir c'est un besoin urgent
pour les Ukrainiens ils sont soumis aux
assurés pétés des forces russes
notamment à baroute bonjour Gulliver
Craig vous êtes notre correspondant en
Ukraine les autorités toutefois ne
baisse pas les bras l'armée continue de
résister et elle compte même très
bientôt tirer parti de la fatigue russe
à darkmouth
alors tout le monde Satan à ce qu'il y
ait une contre-offensive ukrainienne au
printemps mais j'ai entendu beaucoup
d'opinions différentes sur quand est-ce
que cette contre-offensive commencera et
où aussi il y a beaucoup de spéculations
dans le dos de base ou j'étais il y a un
peu plus de semaines des soldats que
j'ai rencontrés me disait qu'il pensait
ou même qu'ils avaient eu l'instruction
en fait de se dire la ligne encore deux
mois avant que de nouveaux recrues
complètent leur formation et soient
prêts pour lancer cette contre-offensive
et que les nouvelles équipements aussi
reçues par l'Ukraine soit tous en place
mais d'autres pensent que la
contre-offensive va commencer plus tôt
et on veulent pour argument pour dire
que c'est pour très bientôt le fait que
l'accès pour la presse a beaucoup
d'endroits près de la ligne de front
c'est resserré ces derniers jours il
devient de plus en plus difficile d'y
aller donc
bien se rappelle le fait que l'Ukraine
avait vraiment fermé l'accès de la
région de Herson à la presse au moment
de la grosse contre-offensive qui a
permis la reconquête de la ville de
Herson à l'automne de l'année dernière
mais c'est vraiment la spéculation pour
le moment c'est plutôt encore les Russes
qui sont à l'attaque même si les
renseignements britanniques et
l'Institut des études de la guerre à
Washington 10 que ils ont l'impression
que l'intensité de l'offensif russe sur
la ville de backgrout est en train de
diminuer et peut-être qu'ils ont déjà
culminés peut-être que c'est parce
qu'ils n'ont plus vraiment de ressources
mais cela peut aussi être parce que les
Russes ont décidés d'essayer de mener
des offensifs plus conséquentes un peu
plus au sud notamment autour de la ville
de abdiveka qui est la ville
ukrainienne tenue par l'Ukraine la plus
proche de la forteresse tenue des facto
par la Russie de depuis 2014 qui est la
grande ville de Donetsk
Gulliver un mot également de se
déplacement du président zellenski dans
la région de Herson est-ce que vous avez
plus de précisions
alors il a visité des villages entre
Herson et mikolaïve donc tes villages
qui ont été terriblement détruites par
les batailles qui ont mené à la
reconquête des personnes par l'Ukraine
j'ai été moi-même il y a 2 semaines dans
la région derrière son pas à cet endroit
même mais je pense que à tout les
endroits où il y a eu des batailles
c'est un peu la même chose les villages
sont complètement détruits il y a dans
beaucoup de villages pas une seule
maison qui est un toit et alors il est
clairement très urgent de reconstruire
the let's qui a permis de tout
reconstruire mais ce qu'il faut aussi
reconstruire c'est l'économie locale qui
est essentiellement agricole et la très
grande problème c'est le fait que les
champs sont pleins de mines et de
munitions non explosées et il faudra de
très longs mois sinon des années pour
que ce pour que cela devienne possible
de renoncer l'agriculture à l'échelle
qu'elle connaissait avant avant cette